Let's consider the
motion of a wheel that's
rolling along the ground with
some center of mass velocity
vcm.
And because the
wheel is rotating
it has an angular velocity.
And you can see that
that vector is directed
into the plane of the board.
Now, what we'd like to do is
consider the kinetic energy
of this continuous body.
A little bit later on, that
body has moved some distance.
And what we want to
consider is the fact
that not only is every
point in the body moving
with the center of
mass speed, but there's
this additional
rotational energy
that's associated with
the fact that every point
in the center of
mass reference frame
is undergoing circular motion.
So how do we describe that?
Well, we'll do that by choosing
some point in the body.
So let's pick a point.
We'll call that
mj, with mass mj.
And the velocity of this point,
remember, has two components.
To simplify it,
we'll give ourselves
a little more picture here.
Every single point in
the object has the vcm.
But because this object is
undergoing circular motion,
there is vcmj.
That's the rotational
circular tangential velocity.
And so the vector
sum of these two
is the actual velocity
vj of the j-th object.
vj is equal to the
center of mass velocity
plus the tangential rotational
velocity that it has,
because it's undergoing
circular motion.
And now what we'd like to do
is calculate the kinetic energy
of this object.
Well, the kinetic energy
is the sum j from 1 to n
of 1/2 mj times the velocity
of this j-th particle squared,
which we can take
as a dot product.
So we can write that as vcm
plus vcmj dot vcm plus vcmj.
And that's just vj squared.
So when we look at these terms,
it looks complicated at first.
But there's some nice-- there's
going to be vcm dot vcm.
There's two cross terms.
They're identical.
And vcmj dot vcmj.
So let's write out
those three terms.
We have 1/2 mj.
vcm dot vcm is vcm squared.
Now, every point in the
object has the same vcm.
So we can pull that
one out of the sum.
And now we'll take
these cross terms.
So we have the sum
over j from 1 to n.
There's two cross terms.
So the 2's are going to cancel.
And inside here,
we have to remember
to keep our mass element.
That's important.
Now, I'm going to write
it as mj vcmj vector.
Now, remember, when
you dot with vcm,
every single point
has the same vcm.
Every j-th element
has the same vm,
so I can pull that vcm outside.
And finally, I
have the last term,
which is the sum over j from
1 to n of 1/2 mj vcmj squared.
And that's just the dot
product of those two terms.
And so our kinetic energy
looks rather complicated,
but let's focus on
this term right here.
Because recall from our
video on the center of mass
that the definition of the
center of mass reference frame,
so if you're moving
in the center of mass,
that in the center of mass
reference frame, the sum of mj
vcmj is equal to 0.
So for instance, if you're
in the center of mass frame,
you're moving with vcm.
The only velocity is this.
And in that frame, the
sum of mj vcmj is 0.
And we did a video
on that one before.
And that's exactly
what's in this term.
So this term is 0.
So this, remember, was
how we defined the center
of mass reference frame.
And therefore, our kinetic
energy consists of two pieces.
This first piece is just 1/2 the
total mass times vcm squared.
And our second piece over here,
we'll just write it out now--
1/2 sum over j mj vcmj squared.
Now, if you are moving
with the center of mass,
then this j-th object is just
undergoing circular motion.
And so we have our
result that we've
used many times is
that the velocity,
the tangential
rotational velocity,
is just equal to
the radius rsj--
so let's introduce that rsj--
times the angular speed omega.
And when we put
that into this term,
we see our kinetic
energy has two pieces--
m total v center of mass squared
plus 1/2 j goes from 1 to n--
I didn't finish that sum there--
mj rsj squared.
Now, just remember that every
single point in the object
has the same angular speed,
and so we can pull out
the omega squared in there.
And because this is a continuous
body and we take the limit,
as we've done before,
as mj goes to 0,
this quantity of
mass times distance
squared is just the
moment of inertia
about the center of
mass of that body.
And in conclusion, K
is 1/2 m total v center
of mass squared plus 1/2
the moment of inertia
about the center of mass times
the angular speed squared.
Now, this is the same
crucial decomposition
that we've talked
about many times.
This first piece is what we
call the translational kinetic
energy, because it
just represents how
the center of mass is moving.
And the second piece
is what we call
the rotational kinetic
energy, because it's
a representation of just the
kinetic energy of rotation.
For example, if you were in
the center of mass frame,
there would be no
translational energy,
and this would be the
only kinetic energy.